hang on a second did he just re-upload
the same video twice
not quite this one has updated visuals
vastly updated ones
the previous video the great white lie
the original version has generated a
healthy amount of discussion and i've
gotten some feedback about
the video itself i learned that the
statute were originally covered that's
nice but i released a video about
immense screeching against white people
a lot of feedback and so i was looking
for a proper avenue to further explore
the points that you brought up
in defense or against the original video
and what better opportunity is there
than a completely visually redone
version of the original one by a very
talented editor so without further ado
enjoy the show and i'll be seeing you at
the end of the video where we'll be
going over the points you brought up
ancient statues are one of the most
awe-inspiring symbols of early western
civilization their masterfully crafted
details and smooth monochrome marble
surfaces give them an almost divine aura
the essence of an entire civilization
captured in stone a civilization that
would later go on to be the world's most
powerful and most developed caesar
augustus and his brilliant white form
represent a sort of divine stoicism
purity whiteness and a big load of
[ __ ] turns out the people of
antiquity really like their colors and
they especially liked painting statues
so how can we associate the ancient
world and their culture with this pure
whiteness which is in complete
opposition to reality also how does
barack obama relate to all this modern
society viewing ancient statues as these
pure white objects began as an honest
mistake really and this originates from
the renaissance era where people started
to appreciate ancient cultures once more
at this point pretty much all ancient
statues were either buried underground
or exposed to the elements for hundreds
of years which caused all the paint to
erode basically and so people at the
time just assumed that this is how these
statues were intended to be now this
wasn't a problem per se what was a
problem is people trying to recreate
ancient statues and buildings based on
this false idea for example here's the
popular building in munich it's a
neoclassical building finished in 1862
and as you can see it is all white or
how about this building which i assume
doesn't need an introduction or this one
and this one is the hungarian national
museum all of them neoclassical and all
of them snow white meanwhile ancient
greeks absolutely loved painting their
buildings but to the modern observers
all these painted statues and buildings
just look weird at exhibitions of
repainted statues visitors have
repeatedly found the colors tasteless
fabio barry an art historian at stamford
described the recolored augustus statue
as a cross-dresser trying to hail a taxi
and boy i sure hope there isn't no
distinct segment of society that ties
its entire identity to this false
aesthetic right so when sarah e bond an
associate professor of history published
her essay entitled why we need to start
seeing the classical world in color she
of course started receiving a bunch of
hate mail from butthurt white
supremacists leftist starter snowflakes
by the way so yeah my biggest problem
with this whole statue color business is
the racial ideology which is built on
top of it this fundamental
misunderstanding of ancient cultures
feeds into this modern myth of white
supremacy the sole purpose of which is
to belittle dehumanize and exclude
non-whites and turns out this collective
misunderstanding of the ancient world is
the perfect breeding ground for such
ideas the reason why you and i might
look at these statues and think they are
tacky or tasteless is because we have
been culturally conditioned to think
that way in contemporary western culture
whiteness came to be associated with
purity seriousness professionalism
cleanliness and most importantly order
and civilization you know it was us the
the whites who built all these nice
white buildings and sculpted all these
nice white statues you know all these
extra colors are reserved mostly for
these silly brown people who live
somewhere down south whom we sometimes
might visit as tourists mind you to
enjoy their silly brown people things
and then once we had our fun off we go
back to our nice white citadel of
progress and development right so this
is the level of the average facebook
boomer i would say but then comes the
white nationalist and says all of this
is because white people are genetically
superior and this might be a very
compelling intuitive argument if you are
below 14 or above 70 but only until the
realization that these far-right idols
are in fact false there is nothing
fundamentally civilized or refined about
the color of white it's a complete
cultural fabrication which by the way
the people of antiquity would have
disagreed with putting out a pure white
statue would have meant that you are too
poor to afford paint and are now looking
to raise money being too white as a male
meant that you are a [ __ ] real man had
brown skin white skin was a thing for
women though but more on a financial
basis as in fair-skinned women being
effluent enough supposedly to not have
to work outside all day long the modern
racialized concept of whiteness just
didn't really exist back then but
through this misinterpretation of
classical cultures we get to pretend
that it did now i know what you're
thinking how does barack obama fit into
all this let me explain barack obama is
considered black he is not considered
white well you know duh obviously right
but hold on a second barack obama is
half white half black so how come he's
not considered both black and white at
the same time well that's because
whiteness is exclusionary its obsession
with purity produces this ever-shrinking
group of worthy individuals a huge air
code surround worthy but what these
identity europa types don't realize is
that this concept is doomed to fail
civilizations that turn exclusionary
will not stand the test of time as they
say the roman empire whose aesthetic
these people love so much could only
grow so great and powerful because it
included people it being an early white
civilization is just a flat out lie the
circle of citizenship the rough
equivalent of whiteness back in the day
constantly expanded the empire losing
its ability to include people was one of
the most important factors in its fall
if not the most important a great
contemporary example for this would of
course be the u.s republican party with
their southern strategy they went on a
path of exclusion instead of inclusion
but after years of presidential
victories the consequences are coming
back to haunt them when it comes to
presidential elections the republican
party has not won a single popular vote
since 1988 except for 2004 fresh after 9
11 and at the start of the iraqi war now
republicans can still theoretically eke
out some victories but through more and
more uninspiring means tell me what does
it say about your political movement
that you have to resort to electoral
[ __ ] to win against hillary [ __ ]
clinton what does it mean about your
racial ideology that you would either
need to deport all non-white people or
forbid race mixing otherwise it wouldn't
survive we have to let this idea go that
the ancient world was white both in
terms of people and statues so i say
let's paint them all the statues that is
all of them should have their original
colors restored let people realize that
their views of the ancient world might
have been false and in the process take
away a major propaganda tool from the
far right and if the colorful statues
upset you i'm sorry historical facts
don't care about your feelings
[Music]
hi welcome back so let's look through
the main points of feedback to the
original video
the first one would be the aesthetic
argument i would call it
and this is that the
color less statues actually look much
better than the colorful ones
because the blank ones emphasize form
better etc etc
but
why is that though i feel like lots of
people fail to consider why they feel
that way because it is just that a
feeling
there is no objective law in the
universe that states
that a
colorless statue a blank statue
emphasizing form is better than a
colorful statue emphasizing well colors
and so i believe that this is well i
know that this is completely cultural
the fact that you think that the blank
statues are nicer
of course we are not
actually i think by the way that the
blank statues
look nicer than the
painted ones those that are painted to
our best knowledge because of course
they don't have any
uh shading any details
we just use the colors that we knew were
there and they don't produce results
that are as nice that which i agree
however i still want them painted
uh because museums you see are not
supposed to be
uh interior design showrooms like i'm
sorry it's just it's a place where
historical artifacts and cultural
artifacts are exhibited and preserved
for the generations to look at
essentially
let's not turn this into a beauty
context because it's not supposed to be
one also have you ever considered that
this
expectation to look nice to look
visually appealing only really affects
you know greco-roman statues uh in terms
of like ancient artifacts you know no
one looks at a a an egyptian painting
and says
we're just just dumb like what is this
like this looks like a child's painting
like this this is terrible no everyone's
like hmm this this looks interesting you
know historical effects okay good
but when people look at the augusta
statue then they suddenly go oh no no no
this is ha this is unacceptable oh no no
no
like this what is this looks looks like
it looks like uh what was the wording
used by that guy in the that i covered
in the video
like a cross-dresser trying to hail a
cab or something
how come greco-roman statues get this
reaction and not
other
artifacts it seems a bit strange to me
and so i think i know the reason why
that's because i believe these statues
became sort of mascots for
essentially white supremacy
of course this was back in the day when
whiteness became a thing this was a
couple hundred years ago back during the
ancient era skin color didn't really
make sense
there were plenty of wide-skinned slaves
and all that counted well one of the
most important things was your class in
society regardless of your skin color
and so a couple of centuries ago this
idea came along that people should now
be stratified based on their skin color
this is still a very new idea in terms
of you know how long our history has
been so far
and in that kind of uh
beginning of uh early white supremacy
these statues just got caught up because
people just didn't really know that they
were colored
and
the blank statues
uh the trium the triumph of the form etc
became an integral part of the symbolism
of this
let's call it ideology or collection of
ideas
meaning like early white supremacy
essentially and we can see today even
that you know neo-nazis white
supremacists
use these symbols very actively very
honestly
i should say
has mascots of that of their ideology
and i believe that this of course does
tremendous damage to society because uh
in the uh like in the youtube post i
made about this i've mentioned that
i am kind of oscillating whether the
statues being white
actually influences people's thinking
that the
statues and the people they depict and
the ancient people are white
i was if you about that at that point
leaning more towards it now now i would
say i believe it
uh based on what i've seen er based on
uh the context that these statues are
used in
it's all
well
but mostly
white supremacist [ __ ] and the
implication is of course always the same
you know europe big building africa
small building therefore white good
white butter you know and so even though
i liked the blanks that she was actually
better than the one with only the base
colors on them
i would still vote for
painting the uh these statues at least
with their base color with as much of
the shading as much of the coloring as
we can verify historically now i don't
know uh how these statues are treated in
this case i don't know if uh if
restorators archaeologists uh paint the
original ones or the uh or the or copies
i don't know how this goes i'm not
myself a restorator or an archaeologist
but um
you know i guess it's up to them but i
would definitely want to see more
colors uh on the statues to
even if that makes statues look worse
from uh but because you have to
understand that they look worse
quote-unquote from our contemporary
perspective an ancient greek or an
ancient roman might might have looked at
the uh colorful statues even the base
colors and say yep that looks better
so the fact that we find the blank
statue is more appealing is just
completely
cultural
and so even though i would prefer
perhaps to see
the nicer looking blank statues versus
the just the ones with the base colors
that is no shading
i would still vote for painting them
because i think uh with a little bit
less of sort of contemporary
aesthetics aesthetical niceness
at the expense of that we can mitigate a
lot of
uh
essentially bad [ __ ] in our contemporary
times we can take away this huge symbol
from white supremacists we can prevent
people from thinking of the ancient
world as this pure whites essentially
classical utopia which then the evil
barbarians came and ruined which who are
the analogues for
all right so let's sum up the answers to
the main points of contention that i
wanted to address
number one would be the fact that
museums
are not interior design showrooms so you
shouldn't go in expecting to look at
something nice unless of course they're
going to a painting exhibition or
something but in terms of statues
aesthetics are not the main priority
when i go into the into a statue
exhibition i want to see historical
accuracy i don't want to see some
falsified [ __ ] uh i want to know the
exact historical context of those
statues how they really looked uh
because i'm not there to look at nice
things i'm there to
look at the truth
you know and those two things aren't
necessarily the same all the time and so
this ties into point number two which is
that our idea that the blank statues
look better than the painted ones
is
cultural
it is completely
cultural that we find form
superior to color
and this is i believe a fairly recent
development
coming from the same era when sort of
whiteness the concept of whiteness
became a thing um and i don't think it's
necessarily helpful or at least people
should be aware of it uh that they're
affected by this and so point number
three would be that we should be taking
away these cultural artifacts from the
far right or we should prevent them from
being able to appropriate them
because that's as you've seen leads to
bad outcomes right so these are my
thoughts that i want to add to this
whole statue saga so once again statues
are not supposed to look nice and if
they don't look nice to you that's
cultural and
we shouldn't let them
look nice so to speak in their current
form because it's a great sort of
cultural tool for the far right which
produces bad outcomes so i believe this
is my main point and i thank you for
watching and don't forget to like and
subscribe and if i have any more of
these addendum segments then we'll be
doing this again and perhaps in the
future i'll be appearing more on camera
we'll see if the video format
provides for it then surely that that
would be the case right so with all this
out of the way i'll be seeing you next
time
[Music]
you